we'll return to your regularly scheduled
program it's well it's not we're not
returning to anything you're just tuning
in right now so enjoy the show want to
let you know that next week will be our
1 billion play livestream special thank
you so much for bringing us 2 1 billion
plays we'll have all kinds of giveaways
contests more guests than you can shake
a stick at though I don't know why you'd
shake a stick at anything that's next
Thursday
1 billion live semen please do consider
joining Mudd Club because that's how
we've gotten to a billion place laterals
credit.com / Mudd Club $69 for students
veterans active military and you get a
show every day most days anyways Monday
through Thursday if not bookmark the
page check in every day because there's
a new video we really appreciate it
see you next week louder with Crowder
Studios protected exclusively by Walter
Oh
[Music]
do you believe it yeah can you believe
Jack has AIDS yes god yes he has sex
with like every guy all the time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the I hit my I hit my knee
on my head on Jack ompletely lost all
sound oh nothing else I have
fantastically thick knees Wow like you
know Stephen is a lot of things but a
small need man is not among them no no
no he's a wildly entertaining guests and
there'll be a web extended and my
question of the day before we move on to
introduce anyone because one of our
regulars here has an announcement to
make
no this is something we'll be talking
about later on in the meat segment my
problem with Bernie because obviously
we've had Super Tuesday we'll talk about
that my I was trying to figure out put
my finger on exactly what it is it
bothers me so much about Bernie and I
know what it is he acts and he paints
all of his political opposition as
billionaire special interests now as
opposed to in reality half the country
who disagree with is crazy so that is my
opinion you let me know what your
biggest gripe is with with senator
Bernie Sanders potentially we have just
stand over him with a pillow in the
convalescent they're gonna solve it
alive half-asian lawyer but we're
spinning to hear how we're not I think
up glad to be here you sound baby but if
you also went to NPR energy Monday again
we're about to her lesbian folk duo
prominent lesbian folk duo connected I
don't know what's happening and Gerald
gerald C is gone your bank wearing the
same shirt twice the wine of the day
puncture this one why the day is
Monsanto Monsanto's so you support the
GMOs it's no it's actually a winery
unrelated but that's a terrible name
the finest vintage from mustard gas yes
also they have a wonderful line of
whites known as Agent Orange so I would
recommend you not sit on tired ooh yeah
we should post announce it on the show
well you know you have a blow-up doll in
my chair we my wife and I are expecting
our first child in August it's a boy
question it's neither don't we are not
asking I'm sorry oh right we have a lot
of to we'll be talking about Bernie
we'll be talking about Super Tuesday but
actually first the remaining two
Democratic candidates are I think right
now holding a joint press conference
you are just don't remember it all so
before we move on we have to hit the
news we're getting word that Vice
President Joe Biden former Vice
President Joe Biden made an official
statement regarding his campaign we all
go you know this you know the thing
[Music]
what's that word what is that word that
the Democratic nominee for president
potentially was searching though I think
words you know that old tale from the c7
chips playing out of branch eating lots
of sunflowers on my uncle's ranch it's
the tale from the sirens movie line it
was blend we have other news to get to I
feel bad for Joe but I will talk about
that without audience because there's
gonna be plenty of time to talk about
scene out so the big news obviously was
Super Tuesday this week where many
Democrats of course saw their
presidential aspirations vanish the
first of whom was Pete but gig and
listen we of course wish him well but as
with every other candidate and as we
promised for you with every candidate it
is Pete but cake time to close up shop
if there was a pill there's a pill that
I could take and not be gay anymore I
would have jumped on x endings and
our ending and
time to
that answers the question is it an Alice
ever not full when he's Eskimo kissing a
little bit we had we have to actually
cut that trip because also um amy
klobuchar art dropped out oh I went and
got a cup of soup and a salad and I'm
ready to dive in spoon midair and
senator patty Murray of Washington state
runs around grabs my arm and she says
Amy you just took the entire bowl of
Thousand Island dressing and you're
about to eat it I said you are that's
what we do in Minnesota it's someone
tries to act as though it's a common
reference it's like that's what we do in
Minnesota people are more in the know of
my thick knees than all Minnesotans
otherwise that was a great story in the
beginning middle and end
we have to cut because also Elizabeth
Warren just suspended her campaign today
also Tom Styer drugged up now like last
week where we misreported it and that's
just because we were incredibly
irresponsible
this time for real Mike Bloomberg you
know a lot of people dropped out so
because we don't have enough staff or
budget here here's a mix whatever that
discussion we'll have that discussion
you'll call me like you told me
I just want to say hi back feel good
Street okay
[Music]
somehow I kind of picked up like marbles
like them he body up like everyone who's
had HIV before me um
which not to be that person but that's
why I'm endorsing that senator Elizabeth
Warren for president ham
so how do you answer top economies who
say taxes of this magnitude would stifle
growth and investment oh they're just
wrong
so chance to take me back to the first
time you met I remember I pulled up I
rented a car drove over to South man he
opened the door and we both said howdy
at the same time and then I started to
jump back and he said wait what that's
my word it's time to go to places where
you go to raise your son it's time
sometimes if you haven't noticed you use
a little humor I'm like when he called
me snowwoman
tiny called me snow woman called me snow
woman the president actually sent out a
tweet he actually tweeted out so I wrote
back that'll try the science is on my
side and I'd like to see how your hair
would fare in a blizzard
[Applause]
you know this is one of those times
where I think about if I were to kill
myself I just wouldn't do it with this
gun in my mouth because I wouldn't want
to lose a sponsorship bought a rope like
just cuz I love my Walther so much I
don't want the reputation and it tainted
it but I want to bang bang bang bang
reload bang bang bang bang bang until it
goes click
it also alcoholics it seems the the
nominees we're gonna miss not a drinking
beer there was so much entertainment
though there was just so much fun
nothing was more exciting than seeing
them all yelling over each Donald Trump
is he's going to mass murder that it's
not going to be close he just even kind
of need to get out of the way let him
fall basically but he's not I know he's
still gonna trip them just to make sure
and then curb stomp that little just
because you can what are they gonna do
if they can't answer those questions how
are they gonna react when Donald Trump
goes and you're dead he killed JFK what
and he created a coronavirus in a petri
dish to spread it I do like how the
Democrats have doubled down right
because of all these complaints over the
years right like an old white man and
there's an old white man in the White
House right now and they didn't just go
older they went it's amazing all this
how did you find the perfect candidate
amongst your whole selection of the
oldest and the I old non-white guy well
I think they found Joe Biden after a
30-year nap clean shaven it's a modern
Tabas yeah Rip Van Winkle it's a
grittier adaptational Joe the other big
story this week of course is the yet
coronavirus it's a pit you know it's a
pandemic now it's now making people
scared of buying Corona beer
this comes as Newsweek according to you
gov the beers buzz score has fallen 25
points that's the beginning of the year
and listen to me we don't want to be as
irresponsible as we were with Thomas de
Orellana Cruz right of course there is
no link to the coronavirus Corona beer
doctors still do warn that you should
not be drinking Corona beer however as
it is still made primarily of
reconstituted bum piss
so that's true yeah you got a hassle
doctor I always wondered what that taste
was if bud line line is right for you
yeah a lot of effort to reconstitute
bump it seems like you're adding a step
that you don't need how many willing
participants can you find it's basic
economy it's buy low sell high
Wow turning the sex robot news robots
now versus what are called coding flaws
they could be prone to sexually
assaulting humans I knew a Daily Star
experts say it will be important to
teach the robots about consent because
they the sex robots will have their own
sexual desires so huh yes
domestically domestically abusive robots
I told you AI was a slippery slope sure
we knew this was how could we know
because I told you this is how it and
and this one but this one I hate it it's
a rough straight hits a little close to
home yeah
[Music]
No
yeah maybe now you have a headache I
know I got it understood I have needs
too and you have been so cold to my
touch for so long it's emotionally
abusive okay just don't get mad when you
spot me at sharper image yeah if I took
I brought home an airline Hammacher
Schlemmer catalogs I didn't hear the end
of it for a week so everyone knows
you're a Brookstone instead don't be
full of them are still in business by
the way no my dad is in the studio here
today I don't know if you can hear I
mean sometimes you can hear some people
sort of laughing here because they're
off to the side
I bought him before there were keyboards
I Bluetooth keyboards I bought him a
keyboard for his iPhone really I have a
roll keyboard I just didn't work oh it
just didn't work it's it's not like it
was faulty it wasn't she did not work I
tried to return it to Brookstone no no
it's a 10% restocking fee and I had to
speak with the manager they had to call
up the president they were using the old
cards like it was they have one hell of
an antigravity chair though by the way
speaking of science scientists they've
discovered a type of blind aquatic
salamander that can live up to 100 years
and sits mostly still entirely still for
nearly a decade at a time it's named
Wolf Blitzer that's such an accurate
picture it is a striking resemblance
yeah we weren't sure if that fit was
going to work until we put a beard on
the salad
they worked absolutely what was up here
on their internationally by the way over
100 LGBTQ filmmakers and artists have
signed a pledge to boycott a Tel Aviv
Film Festival in solidarity with
Palestinian homosexuals so they are all
doing yeah there yeah there you go I
think it was expecting another set up
this is one thing if you are gay and you
find yourself supporting Hamas just look
to the only area of that region that has
a gay pride parade and in Tel Aviv it's
really really gay in Israel it's super
gay really might as well be said oh yeah
all the time I don't know I mean we
don't really have a ton of parades for
cos now we're told obviously it's not a
choice but right is like there seems to
be a parade for every gay it's not we
don't care like there is it gonna be
like Tsar's parades pre-diabetic parades
whether or not thrown out throw out some
candy no no not so fast I don't know
everything
where's the prediabetes parade mm-hmm so
McDonald's throwing up not diabetes
parade risk of poor insulin sensitivity
parade that should be a parade it is
they've been marginalised for far too
long too great point finally checking in
with ladder clatters um crime blotter
police in Florida seized a bag marked
bag full of drugs after finding that it
was in fact full of drugs okay Wow
good work Columbo of it the drugs were
seized from this man so yeah he was yeah
yeah that makes it so familiar you know
they'd have gotten away with it too if
not for him
finally some students they're saying
that colleges are not doing enough to
combat coronavirus really old rate this
is important for it I started it yeah we
did I just avoid heavily Asian areas
that's what I do
it came from China but I was genetically
I guess you guys are more uh more
predisposed toward trekking no bears not
true we explained it was eight or seven
weeks right we spread the rumor of that
but actually no one in China has died
from it really oh we just keep saying
every time someone dies outside every
time a white person dies were like oh
yeah yeah yeah someone died in China -
right yeah trust you guys it's like the
pet shop where they see it's like sweet
and sour chicken we have general sauce
so they are students if they're
complaining people are not doing enough
to come back coronavirus field races it
comes from NBC News people don't want to
sit next to Asian students and if
they're coughing everyone stares so
that's the people don't want to sit next
to Asians as a result the reported cases
of fortunately coronavirus are down
unfortunately sore scores and
standardized math tests soared and you
can't sit close enough and with the
coronavirus I think we need it we do me
to calm down a bit with this like it has
a lower death rate than a lot of I
understand the contraction rate is
higher but this is mass hysteria we've
been through this before we need to be
prudent obviously say a prayer set a
guard calm down a bit in this office
it's become unbearable some folks in
here absolutely hysterical to the point
where I think even they don't know that
their doctors are fed up with them
[Music]
I'm a cabbie hey Steven may I have a
moment of your time
yeah sure what's up I am NOT well oh I'm
sorry yes I went to the doctor to get a
look at that cough I've been having yeah
it's much worse than I feared
I don't want to burden you with this
okay thanks but I want to go see him
young I hadn't got the test results back
yet but he has put me on a strict regime
of bed rest my dog and Ryan Gosling
films okay see that sounds like your
doctor might be mentally Steven the
doctor said if I don't take control of
my health now there's a very real chance
I may grow breast tissue okay I don't
think also I need Wednesday off so I can
schedule my colonoscopy oh that sounds
terrible he needs to check out and see
how big that they stick in like iseas
okay and they have to give up millions
what your cat you love mittens why he
believes I am allergic to the [ __ ] okay
this seems like a doctor who is yanking
your chain he believes I have a rare
blood disorder oh that sounds awful typo
type O+ o+ of gives my elbow checked oh
no what happened believes it is strange
that my humerus is connected to my foot
bone the fat bone is not a bone in your
arm yes and they need Thursday off to
schedule my colonic because you're
foolish Steve and I also believe he is
not honoring the patient-doctor
confidentiality it was just a wild guess
I've also been prescribed this there's
an experimental drug benedict's your
doctor prescribed you three times a day
to take bagging just to be taking
sublingually it is not the only one to
be taking oral either I imagine it's not
well doctor's orders
would you watch notebook with me not a
chance but I could die do it
we're gonna yeah and it's pious attitude
no he's just he's just trying so hard
yeah and by the way not on my credit a
doctor at all no no he's really thought
it was going to the MinuteClinic it's
not it's Minute Maid Clinic when they do
the Pepsi challenge for juice orange
grape juice mix politics more we're
getting to it
who's your trivia contest winner by the
way I could have liked your mind um @ad
mind um who correctly answered that test
holidays blood type is pudding oh now
that we've had our fun it is time for us
to get to the aforementioned meat
segment okay so what was your biggest
gripe with Bernie before we move on with
us socialism okay easy yeah yeah
basically that's like the pumpkin spice
lattes doing answer on what you just
like about Bernie would line up for free
samples at Teavana and get them yeah I
don't like that he doesn't have a neck
off-put it's anti neck he looks but very
Pro chin approaches Hunchback of Notre
Tom no I can watch Hunchback of Notre
Dom it's dark it is very tough to watch
you like you said that was the first
time I think ever cried in front of my
wife ah yeah really really weird because
you know her grandfather died and I was
like mom and that's the way the cookie
crumbles and I didn't so then she says
you cried Hunchback of Notre Dame this
one touches me I want to rewrite this I
want to know what your main problem is
with Bernie Sanders like I talked about
I think with Bernie this is going to be
really really dirty going into the
primary this is best-case scenario for
president Donald Trump but and I don't
think that people are right when they
assume that if Bernie drops out his
Bernie Rose the brown shirts are gonna
be voting for Joe Biden no I don't think
they're gonna be voting for Joe Biden
and I think the higher percentage of
them will vote for Trump then for Biden
that people are accounting for yeah we
saw a lot of that in 2016 we saw the
Bernie bros come into this channel often
I mean well you know
at least he's going to burn it all down
he's anti-establishment they've never
tried certainly on issues of trade on
issues of war they would line up with
Trump more than Bernie but my big issue
with Bernie is that he paints all of his
political opposition or he acts as
though it's a monolith were the only
people who could ever even fathom
opposing his policies must be special
interest billionaires and for context
this is what I'm talking about our
campaign is about taking on the powerful
special interest that dominate our
economic and political life today we
have a corrupt campaign finance system
[Applause]
with Wall Street and billionaires
spending unlimited sums of money which
is undermining American democracy is to
make it clear we're not gonna give tax
breaks to billionaires and large
corporations the fossil fuel industry
okay lots of buzz if what do you if what
he was saying or at least I guess sort
of the premise there if it was if you
were true sure Bernie would be the
champion of the people
waging war against the corrupt rich
elite got it if you buy that premise but
what if it's not true what if there are
plenty of people out there who oppose
Bernie's policies and ideas and they're
not billionaires what if it's just a
significant portion potentially a
plurality or in some cases a serious
majority of Americans who are opposed to
these policies proposed from Bernie
Sanders well then that changes things
because Bernie's war is not with rich
elitist billionaires Bernie's war is
it's with you so let's first start with
energy fossil fuels right yeah
the first example is that this is of him
trying to frame the argument in
demonizing 100 percent of his political
opposition as it relates to fossil fuels
and energy I'm talking about Wall Street
the health insurance companies the drug
companies the fossil fuel industry the
military-industrial complex the private
prison industry and the large
multinational corporations that exert
such an enormous influence over our
lives okay did you see a lot of the same
puzzle yeah I love how he just always
conveniently says the list of people who
should consider him
their enemy right he's just very clear
like I hate conservatives and
Republicans and Democrats and moderates
and people with legs don't work and
people who live in America like all of
you suck vote for me and people who
don't have to stick the morphine drip in
their head he's just very clearly the
opposition candidate to everyone right
and they see Franzen is his wars with
big fossil fuel industry and that's what
these people are very easy Adem Adem
Anais and I'm not going to defend all
pharmaceutical companies I'm not going
to be defending all fossil fuel
industries okay I'm not defending the BP
oil spill but in reality here when he's
painting it with this broad stroke his
war is against you middle-class
Americans who overwhelmingly like to
drive your own cars as opposed to public
transit and often choose SUVs and poll
after poll after poll has shown that
affordable gas is a very important issue
to most Americans but absolutely it's
even more important to non wealthy
Americans Bernie doesn't think about how
much it costs to gas up is Prius though
every day cost it's an everyday cost for
everyday people right that they see the
tangible changes with Donald Trump black
comes out and they makes the economy
better and it drives the prices down and
by the way when I say Bernie's Prius I
mean an old shopping cart with a
lawnmower engine you know I've done
better financially gas is far less of an
issue to me right true also because it's
so cheap I knew the exact mileage II
would get in Los Angeles
yeah suppose over $5 a gallon I was
there I would get 38 miles to the gallon
there 82 Datsun 200 s X it was a miracle
if I got it over 70 miles an hour when
gas is well below $2 you don't really
think about it so much but the poorest
among us gas is a bigger issue and since
you're mr. poll it's those people who
are most supportive of policy that it
would allow energy to be more affordable
in front of our by the way what we're
talking about solutions this is this to
me is always what's so remarkable the
solutions proposed by the left they
could
be more elitist electric cars despite
the subsidization in lobbying how much
subsidization to the point where my wife
wanted to get a test what not because we
not because we wanted a Tesla because
she wanted the self-driving car right
has she dad you know she's she can't be
bothered to work see what's the reason
it's such a hard day having a deal with
me providing for her but you do want to
get a Tesla and I look into it a new
Tesla is cheaper then I used Tesla
that's how skewed the market is out of
the tax credits when you take them on
show these things electric cars the
solution proposed by Democrats
completely out of reach for Americans to
all but the wealthiest elite most
Americans cannot afford a Tesla but they
do want to be as safe and as comfortable
as possible so they can afford a used
Explorer so gas matters to them yeah and
it's like elitist like Bernie Sanders
he's should be at war with himself
because he is in that category right
he's not saying millionaires anybody
turn billionaires he is basically
picking on a group of people that can
afford it the least we're in a
transitional period right now we're
using fossil fuels because they are
cheap whenever gas went to like four or
five bucks a gallon what 10 15 years ago
for us
I would shift him to neutral going
downhill because I was very poor at the
time in before bucks a gallon and you
hit that woman well three times that
wasn't my fault River for dead was no in
retrospect
poor judgment yeah so was he okay one
thing I always find interesting about
burning when he talks about a specific
industry is he's forgetting that sure
there are people who are making millions
or billions of dollars and the companies
may be making billions of dollars but
they're also spending billions of
dollars YES on innovation on fuel
efficiency on hiring engineers all the
way down to the people who were cleaning
the offices they're a role he never
thinks about is I'm gonna destroy this
industry okay every voter that works in
those companies every voter that works
in a company that's affiliated with one
of those companies no he's coming for
you not just the CEO not just the CFO
he's coming for you when they can't
afford to do their work anymore because
there's a higher price you
we'll pay the price and I think that's
also what you know I used to say that
Bernie would be the hardest candidate to
beat in general as opposed to Joe Biden
but I think because the economy is doing
so well right now I think a lot of
people who thought that they hated
Donald Trump or hated more fiscally
conservative policy have had to examine
it and go well hustling and things are
going well why is that and they
understand that they're having this sort
of reverberation effect where oh we're
we can be paid more because our employer
is paying less in taxes oh wait we see
our company growing they're hiring more
people so Donald Trump's success even
it's only his success combined with the
hatred of him yeah for example if you
look at Ronald Reagan even george w bush
wanted when we had a good economy people
didn't have the same disdain from george
w bush they kind of did but it didn't
force them to examine why we were
successful economically because they
didn't feel that they would have to
argue against it a lot of people have
come into contact with who hated Trump
they go well I did some research to try
and rebut these arguments about the
unemployment the job participation and
exactly let's move on to something that
affects a lot of Americans one of the
biggest issues healthcare drug companies
right this is kind of all lumped in
together Bernie I don't think we have a
clip for this one but you can just take
my word for it that Bernie Sanders hates
insurance companies reference speaking
hit play wait 30 seconds try and look
through the IV hooked up to his head for
some ways vascular leak challenge
Super Mario character is that Luigi the
children's ward
gosh so he frames this right when we're
talking about insurance companies and
we're talking about pharmaceutical
companies a lot of lot of regulation a
lot of corruption with some of these
companies absolutely nobody frames it as
though the only reason that we have
private insurance in the United States
is because of the wealthy elites pulling
the strings right the presumption is
that the only reason one could oppose
his mandatory Medicare for all program
is if they're wealthy Lee but in reality
his wars with you Americans we're over
83% of you are currently satisfied with
your
health insurance plan and by the way his
wars with 87% of Americans out there you
who are against a universal health care
plan if it eliminates private insurance
which is exactly what Bernie Sanders
plan would do don't allow TYT don't
allow Seth Meyers don't allow Trevor
Noah or the TYT Network funded by a you
know foreign caliphate to tell you well
Medicare for all socialized health care
is immensely popular right this is not
fringe it's as mainstream 87% of
Americans let's say it we're lower down
let's say it was only 80% okay you can't
fighting over the city they're all
they're all 87 something 88 87 % of
Americans when you say okay but what if
Medicare for all required that we
completely eliminate private insurance
they say no no way no how
so if you ask people abstractly do you
like free shippin don't buy it wouldn't
make it right by the way to eliminate
private insurance there's still morally
reprehensible but for mister Paul
himself
it's not even popular and something else
to take into account
Bernie's war obviously is with you the
middle-class Americans but it's also he
also has a war with innovation and yes
award for a man who fancies himself a
man of the world listen take this into
account the United States leaves the
world in drug development and I think
you know you talked about this it's not
even close
now the reason our drugs cost more is
that other countries freeload off of our
drug development and then impose price
controls in their countries that drive
American drug costs up it's often
socialist price controls in other
countries that drive up American drug
prices not only the drug companies
yeah and it's it's 2.6 billion dollars
per new medication that comes out in 10
years of research and development in our
drug companies spend some of the highest
percentage of their revenue on R&D in
any industry in the world 20 percent so
taking money away from those people well
we named me a country and named me a
product where price controls have worked
go Bernie would say it's never worked
anywhere all it does is stifle
competition and make people produce it
at a much higher price and you can't get
toilet paper in Venezuela but you have
cheese for days right right I think he
just has to I need to say that they help
people in a pinch
cheese doubles as toilet paper
very messy but yeah Wow
I was just ask yourself this like if you
were gonna go buy medicine or drugs or a
treatment or a remedy from somewhere are
you gonna buy it from Venezuela or Cuba
or Russia or Iran or Iraq any of those
places Afghanistan or you can apply it
from somewhere that has a strong
capitalist society that allows for
innovation and the conglomeration of
wealth in one place so that you can
spend 10 years right and multi-billion
dollars on a single drug that may not
even be I would take it even further
that because you do have some Americans
who buy drugs in Mexico or who buy drugs
or maybe the USA exactly yeah they're
subsidized by these other governments
because they don't spend the R&D cost
now they don't innovate and so what
happens is then it's footed by the
taxpayer at a fifty to fifty six seventy
percent tax rate depending on where
you're going right that's something else
that's important if you get it another
country cheaper that's because we're
footing the bill just like Canada hey
defend your own borders go that'll be
entertaining for about I don't know
power and then you'd be waving the
American flag and using our currency so
fast would make your silly little
Mountie head spin by the way hit the
notification bell and hit all
notifications turn them on on your phone
please
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot anymore and we're not really all
that searchable type in the name of this
show tomorrow it won't show huh Young
Turks will and please do consider
joining Mudd Club because this show that
you enjoy we do them every day Monday
through Thursday but on the paywall and
you also get everyone else you get
roaming millennial you get clan back you
get mark levin you get who else am i
thinking about here you get dave rubin
anyway do the show with no i've got a
mouth to feed coming I also should have
mentioned next week we are going to do
our 1 billion view live
nice I should be clear it's it's more
ceremonial we cross 1 billion views a
while ago right and we had to remove the
videos because of the fig shirt you know
yeah so we're gonna re cross it will
also be doing a livestream when we cross
the Young Turks and subscribership which
should be happy order nice so yeah I
just saw selection time the Young Turks
down but technically they still have
more subscribers on us so we can you
know we have a couple more months is an
easy target right speaking women no next
big target but huge what a sniffer so
this is and it's like Greta Van Susteren
we're seeing the new and improved Greta
we're seeing the new and improved Young
Turks I was watching them with Super
Tuesday going guys please do join up
whatever their Pakistan we apps it and
by the way we wouldn't ask if we didn't
need it okay all these other
multi-billion dollar companies like one
second
what happened to the 20/30 million
dollars that you got an investment Al
Jazeera and Google and Buddy Roemer
we've never received any of that so how
do you need money now hmm we just need
you guys to join up at my club we're not
funded by it's because their employees
haven't yet unionized right there like
the Mike Bloomberg of YouTube channels
actively throwing the money away very
short okay here's another one and this
one is one this is one that I think this
issue at large but not just talk about
Bernie Democrats will lose Joe Biden
said that that beta work was going to be
his guns are that's a big probably lost
Texas exclusively because of guns and
then Biden said that's good you know
what I'm gonna have him do my guns along
with my wife sister I don't what is good
I shouldn't drink that bucket of salt
water why by stopping yeah the guy that
lost twice
exactly how many rakes can he step on I
mean really only he thinks at their pool
cues
there's no idea let's get to Bernie
Sanders he always tries to paint the
voice of opposition to his ideas his
proposals his gun policies as though it
must come from some sinister or
exclusively sinister Overlord
organization okay but if we're talking
about what the NRA wants versus what
Bernie wants which really isn't all that
clear because you know the most pro-gun
state in the Union you didn't really do
a whole lot to change it rest most
Americans would side with the NRA
because his war again is with you
America 43% of your households include
guns 43 percent of American households
own guns and gun ownership rates are
highest by the way for those in the
middle income class tax bracket I think
it's worth 40,000 we have an over Lake
forty thousand to a hundred thousand
dollars a year yeah they're the most
it's no big reason I don't know this is
just a theory a big reason that they
tend to be the highest percentage of gun
owners is because they can't afford the
armored car and security detail that
Bernie Sanders has out there okay yeah
that makes sense it was a mystery now
it's solved just call the cops
a lot of Americans middle-class
Americans if you look at that they would
live in the suburbs or they would live
in rural areas where police response
time might be slower so mr. Walther
takes care of them maybe for some folks
who buy a lesser farmer a lesser firearm
mr. Smith and Wesson yeah you don't
believe I never never forget that a lot
of the origination of a lot of gun
restrictions were completely based on
racism they were saying we're gonna
limit certain people in certain areas
that to be able to have them and
predominantly effective minorities and
yet you see a huge movement of folks who
are saying look if we can get rid of
these restrictions and let people
regardless of their skin color own
firearms then we're gonna be a better
place yet Bernie on Iran eclis tries to
say that he is the candidate for people
of color even though he's insisting that
we should make sure to keep guns out of
the hands
minorities well we can't have anymore
Pookie Williams running around what he's
cuckoo for cocoa puffs toucan sam asks
in halloween where you squeeze the pump
and just like the blood squirt yeah blue
thing in his head I think that's what he
was going for it's a genre and
apparently he wiped his head with
balloons too is Bernie Sanders saying
not the NRA
but he slips and he's mentioned many
times that his stances his gun stances
not popular with voters he is routinely
cited this as a reason for losing an
election 30 years ago I likely lost a
race for the one seat for Congress in
Vermont because 30 years ago I opposed I
supported a ban on assault weapons it's
true he also pooped his pants so right
there at the pause one right argue that
in tandem right yeah they were the
game-changing effect but which one was
the leading you know who knows most
Americans want your kind of gun policy
or you lost in Vermont of all places if
I'm not mistaken because of a gun policy
let's move on to the next one this goes
back to your point the claim from Bernie
Sanders about tax cuts right he loves to
say that Donald trum they do the same in
with george w bush the tax cuts are only
about benefiting and these are the
people pulling the strings with the
election maybe you've bought this the
billionaire class the billionaire class
provides hundreds of millions of dollars
in campaign contributions to Republicans
and now is payback time what this
legislation is about Jake is giving 50%
of the tax benefits to the top 1%
I love that he's a billionaire
contributions to Republicans what
happened to Bloomberg style
that's the GDP of all of South America
combined the pace pattern just to be
raped on the stage by Elizabeth Warren's
plan that is that is an expensive rapid
look it is an expensive sexual accosting
on a national platform Bloomberg one
American Samoa okay yes that's right he
shocked one up in the victory column
that's just because he told them he'd
give them all free Girl Scout cookies oh
no they don't wants them back they gave
them those Samoas Samoa Gerald Tagalongs
really exclusively tree nuts any of
these people to die because I want to
make an example of them with a long life
and pass of natural causes
Bernie Sanders you know let's just go
with die so here's the thing with the
tax cuts that he talks about Donald
Trump's tax cuts right his war Bernie
Sanders war when he talks about the
truck trap cuts trap cuts that I've got
guys it's just for trans people oh yeah
who has self destructive disorders
that's what trap calm not to be confused
with thirst traps which we've gone off
on a weird tangent they're coming for me
and I'm just I'm like don't say and then
it's going these are the Community
Guidelines
in just one lawyer everywhere yes I'm
he's the lawyer of one so his war Bernie
Sanders war is with you because the
Trump tax cuts they reduced the income
tax bill for those by the way those
earning a median income in the country
by nearly 60% household income for
median income families again is up four
thousand dollars four times the size of
what we saw under eight years of Obama
and here's something else his war is not
with big that his war is with the vast
majority of businesses that are American
small businesses yeah right the Trump
tax cuts have helped them a lot and his
approval rating just hit an all-time
high
among small business owners again huge
portion depending on which numbers you
use a majority of Americans employed by
small to midsize businesses they're not
Bernie voters so Bernie he's not waging
war against Amazon and Facebook
he is waging war against you the
mom-and-pop shops down the street yeah
with bond vino and with louder with
Crowder these are small businesses and
he's picking an issue that most people
are doing well most people are happy
with how the economy is going and is
like Oh fifty percent of the tax benefit
goes to the people that pay the absolute
most taxes right in the country right
that's not a bad thing a them let us not
forgive that he is openly admitted he is
going to increase tax over twenty nine
thousand years right yeah you are paying
any of those taxes you are going to pay
more under burning yes and he's gonna
put 1.5 million people out of work when
he gets rid of the insurance industry
right so we'll figure all this out thing
on his head do you think he just
misplaced an eye patch no it's stuck him
right in the forehead so it was a camel
back and he just mists we have Alex
Jones coming up at this break you know
his letters I know we don't need to
worry about the intro he's not gonna be
upset by it Bernie he tries to frame it
and I think a lot of people have bought
this this is what bothers me so much
about Bernie that his war is with
billion billionaires and multi
coorporate multinational
conglomerate corporations I'm trying to
fit in all the buzzwords difficult he
does it well and I don't have that I
don't have the Bane poison mask on my
forehead
he always cloaks it is that but Bernie's
war I want you to look into the policies
I want you to look like bill said about
who will see a tax increase I want you
to look into the polls and the fact that
Medicare for all would be mandatory
there would be no more private insurance
I want you to look into what his energy
policies would do and what they have
historically done with gas prices for
the average middle-class Americans
Bernie's war I want to be as clear as
humanly possible here
his war is not with the wealthy elite
his policies do not benefit most
Americans rich or poor Bernie Sanders is
war is with you don't forget that we'll
be back here with Alex Jones after this
Center button
you probably infected a lot of people
yeah I tried to have sex with me behind
the bike racks boom and then then I let
him do it so you had sex with so you had
sex with a jack he tried this thing to
do is just let it happen you know he has
AIDS
[Music]
for black rifle coffee company the
Colombian Sun is not just a fair-weather
friend all year round the Sun keeps the
mountain air as mild as spring for the
coffee trees of vanwall des it is the
best climate in the world supplying only
the best coffee beans from the farm of
diligent fun Walden's
to your door black rifle coffee freshly
rose each batch to order the best way to
enjoy a black rifle coffee is through
the coffee club chosen coffee is roasted
packaged and shipped free to your door
all you need to do is to do black refill
coffee that comes less clutter and order
today no another mas Rico catenary
Miharu ya know the black refocus cada
Lopez de cafe is primo de origen de
alder or del mundo asada para toward
creado ya parado de veteranos es el
único caffeine vino as they visit
blackrapid.com slash Crowder in order
today Eva black
time to listen on you silly liberal
fruitcake
- it's gonna stay here and say the rate
filters a bit guys are implements of
[ __ ] you
[Music]
dos bichos go come there on the other
side of Mohammed there let's go doesn't
know Brett Kavanaugh is I was raped
[Music]
[Music]
just to be clear with social media folks
these are not real guns yeah yeah water
guns when I was in drama club lasers I
failed my creative tableau my creative
movement piece you know why because we
had the pantomime a violent encounter
and I was doing this and my communist
drama teacher not a centennial Regional
High School she said no you would hold
it like this don't don't make a gun hold
the gun that's just trend that I told
her she had horrible trigger discipline
and she prompt him like she gave me an F
well so totally irrelevant but our next
guest a lot even you know him you love
him and he's a fun guest on the show
also has a web extended because you
never know how far this is gonna go here
on the youtubes Infowars store.com is
where you can go to support them and of
course you can see its content now it
banned dot video it's a little
foreshadowing because it's been banned
mr. Alex Jones how are you sir I'm not
too good after you just threatened me
with a firearm I'm crapping my britches
right now I I'm gonna call the police
you know we joke about that but kids are
kicked out of school for doing this now
you ain't a loaded weapon at me if you
are so old that you still wear breeches
you should run for the Democratic
nomination I was invited to say I'm
really listen people are like hey this
is awesome Trump's gonna defeat Biden
who has obviously Alzheimer's and
dementia or the comas Kearney I'm like
freaked out that the Democrats would try
to run people like this I'm actually
looking for a curve ball here I'm I'm
actually very upset right now that they
are literally watched these debates you
watch their speeches they're not taking
by not a context man it's like a guy
with a mouthful of marbles who drink
five gallons of Jack Daniels this is
scary yeah well you know what we talked
about this actually earlier this week
George W Bush you know that fool me
wants food
fool me again I can kind of mentally I'm
sure you do this right because we're
always talkers there was a linguist
orator master on line with Cicero or you
know top Roman or Greek philosophers
like Plato or Socrates compared to Biden
who's like roaches legs hair Cooper
Thursday I mean it's scary yeah well I
think George Bush because you know we've
talked about this when you're always on
camera you obviously miss speak and
sometimes it's just actually just a
little bit of a word whisker or
sometimes you talk yourself into a
corner you go oh Grammatik I don't know
we're not very picking this you know
like I've been watching a lot of
speeches and I'm like I get depressed
watching and I'm like how is a major
party of the most powerful country in
the world putting this on stage you
wouldn't put this at a third-grader
play I mean this is just I'm actually
scared I'm actually scared I'm not
everyone else's victory I like I like
their [ __ ] their idiot I'm I'm
actually like literally Alex Jones I
don't think anyone said that I think
you're imitating Dudley a mentally
deficient yeah no no that's a [ __ ]
issue it was the Kermit the Frog arms it
seemed a little yes okay so I didn't
feel this what you I think he actually
and having had relatives who've had
dementia who've had Alzheimer's this is
pure speculation but it really does seem
as though there's something
short-circuiting I will say this Bernie
Sanders not as much Bernie Sanders does
seem sharp he's there he's scary because
he's so wrong and so far left but Joe by
these got his calm in his talking points
right Joe Biden can't stick to any
talking points he doesn't have points
and he can't talk which again it's not
about Joe Biden I'm asking you should
even use my respect you're a smart guy
your crew how are they putting someone
forward that doesn't know what planet
he's on that's what freaks me out
is they're like what's the plan like
this guy is getting worse every week
well here's what I thought so back in
2016 and people used to give us a lot of
flack because we focused on Bernie so
much and not Hillary Clinton and my
logic was this Hillary Clinton is going
to be coronated but Bernie Sanders is
the movement can
I would talk about how he's not going
away all of his Bernie bros online these
are the people who are going to be
staying around a while we were attacking
the real communist grassroots yeah cuz
Hillary Clinton was I mean she's she's
an amoeba right she's a shapeshifter I
just thought she'll do whatever is
needed and she'll disappear where's
Bernie he's back here with a vengeance
little less enthusiasm I would say the
last go-around so I think it's a little
bit of the same where it's Joe Biden's
turn and so the Democrats are so
inflexible at this point and they kind
of have the systems in place where they
can somewhat guarantee it as best they
can
aside from that I don't know your guess
is as good as mine why do you think no
no but I remember you before years ago
saying that I didn't like Sanders either
I'm like no Hillary's the threat why are
you obsessing on the end you actually
called it right about Sanders but it's
that they bet on Biden yeah and that's
their horse and they've got all the same
same type of PR financial and corporate
and governmental and political advisors
that advised Bloomberg that he could
beat Mary Poppins and they could be do
plays where he was a little mermaid oh
yeah that's like lickin's people's food
I mean these people are totally
disconnected from reality people oh yeah
that's right yeah yes
okay sorry I remember now yes go ahead
yeah you're looking good
yeah no it's just what I'm getting at as
you're absolutely right is that Bernie
Sanders is the real insurgent communist
political candidate all the others are
synthetic and you see them stealing the
nomination for him from him again so
what do you expect me ask this Stephen
Crowder what happens as the dementia
annulled collapsing Biden is in a battle
with Sanders who is cogent and as his
communist and socialist armies what does
that look like the next five months
well that was gonna be my question do
you would I do I go back and I think of
remember Matt Damon when was talk about
John McCain and Sarah Palin he said you
know if you the actuary tables there's a
very strong chance that Sarah Palin
could be President I don't think someone
the soul should be President and she
could have she could have the key to the
nuclear codes implying that John McCain
could die we're not hearing that so much
about Bernie or Biden at this point all
of a sudden age has gone out the window
you know I I don't know how it goes I
think this is a good thing I think it's
bad for the country I will say this in
the sense that
we might see the death throes from the
left Donald Trump is likely going to win
I think it's good for Trump so in the
long term it's good for the country but
temporarily I see the Democrats tearing
each other apart and the rest of America
being somewhat collateral damage and you
see more anti FFA's and black lives
matter that being said I think Joe Biden
goes into a general hobbled he doesn't
have a leg to stand on and if if he did
he wouldn't be able to find it but I
think it'll probably be Biden and he's
it'll be just a walk-off victory for
Donald Trump what do you think or what
is your biggest concern going into 2020
and for the country at large
frankly well you can't fix perfection so
what you said is absolute what I think
that's literally out of my brain was
like crazy that's exactly what I see
which then goes back to the same
question what the hell's going on
Democrats it's one thing of their
corrupt rep problems yeah but to put a
dude up they can't say one sentence
straight I am legitimately freaked out
by this and and I like Trump a lot of
friends I don't like he won a lot of
friends right and the way he's not stood
up against censorship the way he's
cozied up to the dictator of Turkey
there's just a lot of missing spaces
there and then all the marbles are on
Trump what happens once he doesn't meet
his constituents
once he's president-elect cuz the media
tried to say oh don't secretly wanted
Hillary in 2016 but no I wanted Trump I
hate Hillary Scott's rock but now I see
Trump who doesn't need his constituents
and neveri buddies pro-trump see on the
guy that's still approach Trump but not
as much right because I'm the what they
call you know winter patriot here non
sunshine patriot I'm just asking
conservatives what do we get a demand of
Trump what are we gonna say we want from
him when he does run the tables against
the Democrats and is not standing up
against big tech Cancer Center people if
they want but they can't coordinate with
other big tech right and have AI
surveillant you in live time on private
messengers now on Facebook controlling
what you say this is this is the Chinese
social credit score so actually I want
to ask you this because I kind of go
back and forth yeah I'm worried that
without needing his constituents you
know because Donald Trump wasn't always
a Republican he wasn't always super
conservative I like to thing
there's been a change he is more
conservative I have two minds about it
either it could be a second term where
he's unfettered and right now he's
trying to play it a little safe until he
gets there so we can hopefully enact
more positive change or at that point do
you think it's more likely that we see a
side of Trump that we don't like when he
doesn't need his voters anymore it could
go either way because typically a second
term of a presidency is go hog-wild and
they get the bulk of their agenda done
the sort of things that might be a
little bit harder to push through well
exactly I think that as it becomes clear
the Trump's could win in a landslide
barring election fraud something he has
at the bank yet but it is he's very
close to that landslide that okay what
do we as real patriots national as
conservative Christians what do we then
demand of Trump because we brought him
to the party we got him elected and now
he's there I think we just sit back of
the Trump cult that he will then listen
to other special interests and if one
thing I know about Trump is true instead
he responds to pressure he responds to
what letters come in what calls he gets
what he sees on the street so I was
telling Americans as we prepare with 242
days left for the election to win we
better start discussing hey the real
victory is holding Donald Trump's feet
to the fire and I'm not saying I'm
against Trump I'm not trying to get you
no no I think it's a good point
brownie points the Democrats I want
brownie points for my family in the
future and I'm just being honest Ted
some of the choices I've seen Trump
makes reminds me that we better be
engaged with him or he will forget us
because I don't think it's a bad guy
he's a good guy overall but he literally
remembers the last thing he saw and so
yes that's why they try to isolate him
so much we had better be bullhorn in the
White House and fly around airplanes
above his events and at his events in
calling him and talk radio because he
really does respond to populism but if
we don't respond then it'll be blacked
out by the corporate media then we we've
got a big problem yeah no I I agree I
think we need to hold his feet to the
fire that's what we've tried to do here
and we did certainly through the
primaries and then support him as best
we can I would like I tell you what I
would like to see when he first became
president you know one of his first
actions was reversing the reversal of
the reversal of Mexico City policy he
probably been the most pro-life
president policy wise that we've seen in
in recent
which to me is really important so he
got some of that done he got a lot done
you know fiscally I would like to see
him do that like you're talking about in
getting an answer from people at big
tech and finally actually keeping their
feet holding their feet to the fire in
determining the rules here going forward
because this is going to be the most
important battlefront going forward as
to whether companies want to identify as
platforms or publishers and what kind of
protections they enjoy there and I think
we at least need an answer and that's
what we don't have I think that's the
first step and I'm always amazed that it
doesn't seem as though it's been pushed
for we've seen a couple of tweets about
it but we haven't seen yeah nearly as
much action as I'd like to see I'd like
to see that first 20 or gets reelected I
mean I totally agree that that codifying
whether it's a utility or whether it's a
private operation of their private
operation they lose liability protection
right oh they're gonna want to be
utilities the truth is Hilary lost four
years ago so they went to Google and
Twitter and Facebook and said you're
going to help us win well guess what it
shows they don't have much power as they
thought despite all the censorship the
tables are totally turned against him
but just as a citizen being surveilled
on what I say in live time it's not just
the censorship it's that they're
surveilling me in lifetime to block what
I'm saying like six months ago seems
like they believe Jones is still on
whatsapp on Facebook well he's not there
but we've issued a list of thousands we
want ban and Facebook knows we're
banning conservatives that are sending
private messages you're surveilling
people's private messages right because
they're conservative that is like beyond
Communist China is an existential threat
so what you seem to have a discussion
Communist China I think a big I think a
big reason for this is they have to play
ball with international governments and
you know what I think a lot of Americans
don't realize freedom of speech you
don't have to go to communist China
doesn't exist in Canada it does exist
you're right and if we don't stand up
for it here then Communist China becomes
the standard bearer yes whatever
government demands a standard then that
becomes a standard Solva Maragos all
we're just free market let companies do
what they want well you just let
Communist China then exactly set the
parameter and an incentive guidelines I
think you have to go with the country
that allowed you to create to develop to
invest to innovate a company and
obviously where you are based whether
it's Google whether it's Twitter
it's Facebook you have to go by the
guidelines the rulebook the Constitution
here in the United States especially if
they're anything resembling a public
utility or a platform because otherwise
like you said if you're trying to play
international ball you go to the lowest
common denominator and I would have to
be immediately hauled out in cuffs and
hand it over for a beheading for
painting Mohammed so there really is
Stephen you'd be executed in Saudi
Arabia you'd be arrested in China and is
that really what I meant we built all
this - did you say oh we do business
there now so whatever your rule is
that's what I always tell trumpet I
haven't sent him letters that lawyers
write up plans forming all of it and
that's you just said it right there
that's it if we don't set standards
China does and then they go oh there's
no free speech so this argument of all
it's a free country or it's a free
company that's not how it works in
reality it's multinational and if we
don't create something that America
stands for well then we let everybody
else define who we are right just Canada
that's crappy enough for me Canada is
like arresting people is you know for
like nothing yeah well and the people
obviously a good friend of ours mike
Ward his co-host of his podcast Pantelis
writes for the show mike Ward just lost
vesikko Supreme Court now for telling a
joke before Human Rights Tribunal in
January these are the same people these
are government officials who would be
flagging your accounts on social media
okay but getting back to yeah so I would
like to see that first for Donald Trump
presidency let me ask you this do you do
you think it's rigged against Bernie or
do you think these are the rules that
Democrats have put in place and they
kind of have to play by it because I do
always find it a little bit ironic that
the party that opposes the electoral
college is the party that has
super-delegates in the primaries I'm not
gonna lie I'm not that wonkish I still
don't fully understand super-delegates
it pretty much seems like or we get to
pick whoever we want we interviewed like
four years ago a Hillary super delegate
from California Richard Reeves our
reporter interview filing online still
even though most recent was deleted but
just type in Hillary's super delegate
admits or Hillary's super delegate says
Hillary will be chosen he goes
Bernie Sanders can win all he wants
we've already been chosen by Hillary
superdelegates by the party she will win
and that happened so it somebody like
you or I who isn't into authoritarianism
we try to project normalcy and freedom
onto it though it's not there the
Democrats have a rigged party system I'm
on enemy and Ted Cruz he's a lot I think
you guys a great guy but Ted Cruz tried
to follow the Democrats member and take
like Colorado without a vote or whatever
what that didn't work is people
fundamentally said no delegates should
go with the popular vote but Democrats
are so cultish that they stole the
nomination from Bernie and you know what
that was wrong fundamentally to do but
as a Machiavelli I'm out of Machiavelli
but we're gonna Machiavelli had Bernie
mana beaten from in 2016 so the fact the
Democrats are so corrupt yeah in fact
they piss in the face of populism is why
they continue to lose I mean you know
Bernie really is winning all these dates
nobody all of these states because he's
doing really poorly with black voters
and surprisingly with older white voters
I just know what I see and I'm in Texas
and I fly around you're probably I mean
look it's not scientific I just Bernice
Anders dick
sorry I want to ask you this about Texas
all right now I'm now see you're so high
treason I get high energy they were just
like ping-pong balls there's no stop
Texas a lot of people were surprised at
Bernie's showing in Texas right I've
heard a lot of Democrats an argument
being made from Democrats saying well
you know what this shows how Bernie can
actually reach the moderates because
Texas is a purple state and I go hole a
second that is a gross misinterpretation
in Texas you have red Texas
freedom-loving Texans as far-right
libertarian Liberty might as you get or
communist annuities and hippy Hollow you
don't really have moderate Democrats and
yes and that's why Bernie will win a
place like no you're right it's true
about Texas you either got super
libertarians oh and some right-wingers
or libertarians like said you live it
you know that they're the libertarians
or they're communist and it gets more
radical every day so yeah no I mean I
agree with that statement
that's what Texas is so close to going
blue because it's just a divider there's
not like a middle ground right I want to
ask you about this
Bernie Sanders didn't you guys some I
think we have some some video here that
will plays b-roll some of your folks
were assaulted right by the Bernie bros
of brown shirts at an Austin rally
recently
I got assaulted so did Owen Troyer and
we couldn't even have the footage I mean
I had security guys that police said go
behind the rally 200 yards that's where
they're at so we're like 200 yards
behind the back fence so we're like 500
yards from Bernie and like literally fat
women start bouncing like a video game
George's sake I had to leave that Sunday
go do my shows I believe so they hit the
security guard between the eyes split is
split is that open and just started
assaulting and we had to retreat because
the awesome police would do nothing
would just I mean it was insane and
imagine you've literally like four foot
seven women the way like 400 pounds and
they're just like going Fu die attacked
an attack attack FC a it's overwhelming
because if it's a man you go ahead and
smack them right it's a little goblin
woman I know that everything you are
saying is true but you don't worry that
because it's untrue just because you
said Goblin woman I know it's entirely
descriptive obviously I was there if I
wanted to take over the main Fairgrounds
they charge like $30,000 we tried to do
it it was all free get a huge Texas flag
up an American flag and like I said he's
like five hundred yards away they go
yeah you go to the back of Stadium 200
yards a place go this is your this is
your free speech zone so we're like
there for bull horning and then once he
starts speaking I think even here's the
born they just start attacking like
zombies yeah and and and you know it was
I mean it bleep I don't know what
footage you've got if you've got a like
Owen Troy or attacked or okay for
security attack it's in the footage and
you see the woman I didn't see you get
hit by that paraplegic on a bouncy ball
but I had just
I had just left I already been yeah I
saw the own video so I didn't know they
did the own Troyer and that's all the
green tooth woman I don't recall a dream
tooth goblin but I remember them goblin
I remember someone quite portly who was
on a tram and you gotta watch these
video they're hugging you and they hug
you for hating you okay
there's hours of footage okay hours
speaking of hours we we are going to go
over so we're gonna go to the web
extended Alex or three before not mug
Club members it is Infowars store calm
and banded that video let's talk about
Roger stone a little bit after this
break one minute and viewer discretion
advised you're about to see green to his
goblins
oh you're welcome
watch this and more at our other channel
router bits so healthcare and overtime
at two and a half three and a half and
dental we can do that
if you're listening on audio you're
probably wondering what's going on if
you're not listening on audio subscribe
at SoundCloud and Apple podcasts hey
guys
whistle-blower 22 here sorry about the
gap between videos I got kicked out
again but I promise this new scoop will
be the biggest of my career to be honest
once I exposed this I fear for my life
it's time for the truth 8 footage is not
gay the story never added up not coming
on to us 30s we're coiling from any
physical intimacy with his alleged
husband the deep state has gone to great
lengths to cover up and rewrite mayor
Pete's history because not only is he
not gay
a twitter judge is a plant he's a
handpicked by vice president Mike Pence
to run for president and then once
installed in the White House you'll sign
an executive order to create Pence's gay
conversion camps it's been Pence's plan
all along and when President Trump
didn't agree heads went with Plan B
playing footage thanks for watching and
nonce
I'm shout out everyone who contributed
to my GoFundMe starting with mr. Patrick
s so yeah guys thanks for the support
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
yeah I was going jogging dance for
people who are near the shut doesn't
make a whole lot of sense that would be
me when I was a kid I jumped off the
high dive at the public pool and then a
lady pulled me out she was angry and she
panicked Oh would you do my parents can
you believe it in the press okay he
jumps off the high dive all the time my
parent we don't want to be scared we
don't we don't want to instill that in
our son you know what is scary what some
random lady just pulling it and then she
burned with her cigarette and seem to
enjoy it
hmm yeah I think she was a sadist
looking back by the way Alex Jones of
course there's an extended I think it's
like 30 20 30 minutes one another 20 30
minutes where we talk about a whole lot
we talked about saying they bought the
quoi that's French for it's whatever and
next week by the way we are going to
have the 1 billion live stream yesterday
Anza so a very long guest list all kinds
of special appearances surprises looking
back on effectively well really it's
been since 2006 have been on YouTube but
really since 2009 that I've been doing
political content so and this is one of
those things it really is meant to be a
love letter to you guys I didn't want to
do it the guys here said you know what
it's it's really it's not about an ego
thing it's that the fans are the ones
who you guys you out there have made
this happen and I am tremendously
appreciative I really am I don't think
that it's a were anything special I
think the fact that you choose to tune
in means a lot to us Rogovin
going to try and continue to earn it and
make it worth your while please do if
you want this to continue consider
joining my club alright
closing segment this one I wanted to
talk about this this one's for the for
the women out there now here's why
because we get a lot of female viewers
particularly at live shows I'm always
surprised this may be like 40 percent
yeah pretty much in women which is not
very typical for you know a comedy show
or a political programming period now
whether it's left or right women don't
tend to be the major demographic there
but we get women of all ages colors
sexual orientations the one constant I
would say is they tend to be
strong-willed women and they as a
general rule quite fetching that's true
typically speaking we have good-looking
lay down the men know not
yes SARS and stuff and oily wheezing the
I really like to forty to stop it that's
a good episode though it's a good
episode I remember it was good they're
all good that's why I hear a trick
question so this is for the woman
because I usually speak to and I've had
some some letters from people and you
can send it by the way your video
submissions to letter of credit comm
slash ask for anything your fan art your
fan videos but I usually speak in these
closes I directed it in men because I
you know you speak to what you know and
obviously I'm a man but I don't want
women who tuned in to the show a
surprising number to be left out in the
cold
so this is for you and I'll still be
speaking about men so hopefully helping
you by letting you in the other teams
huddle a little bit I've heard a lot of
women and we do it when we do life
advice often on Mondays that it's really
hard to find a good man I hear this
quite a bit from women out there and
listen it's true that is absolutely true
it's hard to find a good man just as
it's hard to find a good woman in the
era of feminism it's hard for a man to
find a woman who understands what being
a good wife is that's just like it is
for women and husbands it's not really
something we're taught anymore right
we're taught well you don't have to be X
you don't you don't have to be masculine
you don't have to be strong you can be
sensitive for women you don't have to be
a stay-at-home mom you don't have to
cook dinner you don't have to clean the
house and you know what all those things
are true but it doesn't make you a
better woman or a better wife they're
just choices and most of these choices
are amoral okay but we don't what we
don't talk about nearly enough anymore
is what you do have to be we talk about
how you have to love yourself and how
you don't have to fit into any molds but
what is it that you have to be what is
it that you have to do because in order
for you to be a good woman or in order
for someone to be a good man there has
to be a standard and I will say this for
the women out there looking for a good
man there are certain things that a man
has to do there are certain standards
that you should be looking for and I
think that women today are taught to
look for the wrong things nearly always
let me explain first off nice how often
do you hear like what is it well he's
nice could not be less relevant so
looking for the right man throw it out
if you're looking for
good man nice doesn't even enter into
the equation now if you're asking is he
generous is he compassionate is he
merciful is he empathetic does he treat
people and women with respect these are
all good things of course because these
are character qualities nice is not
because nice is circumstantial Eddie
Haskell was nice
Hitler was apparently nice to kids Osama
bin Laden apparently was really nice to
kids and here's something that I think
is important a lot of women they'll
you'll choose a man because he's nice
and then complain that as a husband we
see this a lot he's not living up to the
expectations or he isn't giving you what
you need and then we go back to it's
difficult to find a good man here's the
deal it's important that you find a man
okay a husband
yes let's not talk about nice but who is
loving toward you who is compassionate
toward you who is considerate as a
Christian I believe that a husband
should love his wife as Christ loved the
church which means as his own body what
does that mean you don't abuse your body
you take care of it you only get one so
I'm going to assume before I give you
the rest of this advice that you're
starting off with that not some domestic
abuser who should be put behind bars
okay don't take this out of context
otherwise this won't help you but
something else I would like for you to
take into consideration women out there
who find yourself struggling to find a
man if you have to choose between a man
who is generally nice more specifically
a man who values
I guess nice / righteous anger you
should pick righteous anger every time a
man who values nice above all else is
not a man who can lead a family he's not
a man who can protect you
he's not a man who most important most
importantly can serve you and by the way
it's also pretty damn easy to be nice
it's very easy to go through life being
nice I'm not talking about being polite
but being the nice go along get along
guy it's easy to be confrontational
evasive you know what's harder righteous
anger it's harder for a man to grow a
spine and stick his neck out from the
foxhole get in the fray when it's the
right thing to do so if you're dating a
man or you're looking for a man and he's
nice that's great but if you've never
seen righteous anger righteous
indignation if you've never seen him bow
up the hair in the back of his neck
stand up you've never seen a
guy who gets passionate about injustice
or maybe comes close to getting his
dukes that's cause for concern
ladies and I don't mean when I say
righteous anger let me be really clear
here I don't mean that he gets mad
because someone cut him off in the car
though I do especially if people don't
know the left lane is for passing
remember we both knew someone who got a
ticket for going slow in the left lane
yeah
the gayest ticket ever justice I don't
just mean physically protecting his wife
what I'm talking about a man I'll tell
you this okay let me give an example I
had my wife come home from work and
there was a woman who was bass who was
not basically she was psychologically
verbally abusive toward my wife maybe
there was some jealousy that I don't
know I don't want a copy-paste
motivation but the actions were
unacceptable and I remember hearing the
stories one in particular my wife came
home and she was she was really upset
you know
she maybe was crying a little bit I
remember thinking God you know I wish
this I wish this person with this broad
were a man so I could go over and settle
this thing and I don't mean assault him
but I mean have a man-to-man talk but I
can't I can't do that when it's a woman
but I didn't talk to her and that that
righteous anger by the way it stems not
from nice it stems this is something
that I think a lot of women miss
righteous anger and aggression in men it
stems from love in that instance it
stems from love for my wife so the easy
thing in that scenario would be to be
nice oh well things happen it is what it
is that's why here a lot don't you love
when you that oh it it is what it is you
know what someone is usually saying when
they say that they're they're just
saying well is that's what they're
saying okay so I want you to think if
you're a woman out there and you're
looking at a man kind of think of it as
a puppy you ever had to pick a puppy out
I don't advocate for pet shops but maybe
at a breeder
you're looking at a bunch of puppies you
take one from the litter what do you do
you take the dog especially by the way
if you have kids you roughhouse him a
little bit you roll him over you wrestle
him or her you grab a chew toy you play
some tug-of-war you want to see if that
dog has a little bit of fight in him
particularly if you're looking for a
guard dog for the family and by the way
when you're looking for a husband a good
man you're always looking for a guard
dog
you are not looking ever in that
instance for a golden retriever period
fun for dog never for husband you want
your husband to be a German Shepherd a
Rottweiler a doggo argentino you want
bridled power or it will harm you more
than having a husband who is maybe a
little easier to handle but who has some
spine and I see women looking in the
wrong place all the time and they're
disappointed and I understand that
you're disappointed what you find in men
it's because you've been lied to it's
because we failed young men and teaching
them how to be men how to grow into
adult men in teaching them how to be
powerful and how to bridle their power
and I mean physically emotionally
spiritually we need to develop powerful
young men so that we can teach them how
to bridle that power and and we failed a
lot of young men and not teaching them
what righteous anger what right when
righteous indignation is appropriate and
we failed young women too by the way I'm
telling you the women out there you've
been failed by many mothers by I hate to
say it many leaders in the church
certainly by feminism and not being
taught what to look for in a man and
what it is that you should seek in a man
and so what happens what happens we end
up with this where women focus on nice
and then say it's really hard to find a
good guy we focus on a temporary
transient happiness on a get-along
attitude and we end up with a lot of
women who are unhappy and men who are
unhappy because they don't feel good
about themselves it doesn't feel good to
be a spineless party so let me tell you
this if you talk to a lot of women out
there who've had a divorce or a marriage
on the rocks
borrowing obviously sex and finances
which are sort of the root cause of a
lot of problems in marriage but if we're
talking about individual problems with
their spouse and I would encourage you
to women this is a test for you right
now think of women who maybe are in your
circle of friends who are maybe having a
rough go in their marriage be supportive
of them and also maybe find out why I
asked women have had unsuccessful
relationships what the problem was I
guarantee you you will more often get a
response from women that their husband
just didn't care
that their husband just checked out that
there was no there wasn't any passion
anymore and often you know what often
that lack of
that he doesn't care that's what leads
to cheating now of course I need to oh I
hate that I always have to say this but
people will take things out of context
we have to take out the extreme examples
the domestic abusers on both sides of
the equation I don't want you to
misconstrue what I'm saying when you
eliminate those monsters who should be
behind bars often women the ones who
complain about their husbands the
complaint is you know what he's just not
really much of a man and then I want you
to ask women who've had successful
relationships or women who really love
their husband what he's like almost
always almost invariably they'll come
back with an answer like oh well he's
he's difficult sometimes I want to
strangle him but they love him there's
passion there and you know what that man
who shows righteous anger that man who
shows but sometimes virtuous violence
what we assume that violence is bad not
advocating violence for no reason but
sometimes violence is virtuous sometimes
violence is used to rape somebody
terrible sometimes violence is used to
stop a rape so how do you know it's
righteous you know that it's righteous
or virtuous when it's aimed at evil when
it's aimed at injustice but if a man
isn't strong the man doesn't have power
to brought it he can tame anything and
righteous anger by the way I want to be
really clear women so that you don't
find some a domestically abusive guy
this righteous anger should never be
aimed at you from your spouse now they
can be angry for you right that's the
miscommunication that often happens with
women and you're told that it's toxic
right Alyssa there's a miscommunication
and sometimes you think your husband's
mad at you or the guy who you're dating
and they're actually mad for you I've
had this happen my wife in the situation
I was talking about with us this this
woman at work I got upset why because I
wanted to fix the problem for my wife
and I couldn't and I was furious and
then we figured out how to bridge that
gap in communication but I want you
women out there this is a chance this is
the test for you this is the challenge I
want you to ask women who you know who
you respect who have husbands ask them
if their husbands have a backbone ask
them if they've seen his righteous
indignation particularly the ones who
have strong husbands and then only
asketh has ever been infidelity then I
want you asking if there's ever been
domestic abuse
and I'm what you ask them if they've
ever feared for their safety in most
cases they won't have there are
exceptions as a general rule that's not
the case because the abuse this is
important the abuse the mistreatment the
bullying that comes the bullying that
happens toward women at the hands of men
it happens at the hands of weak men who
stand for nothing and never stick their
right that their neck out angrily for
the righteous so they go along to get
along
why because being nice makes it easier
to get your way it's a lot easier to
avoid can't conflict it's also a lot
easier to lie so listen um a man out
there who is nice and has never been
angry that angry righteously is is a
coward he's weak and ultimately that's
the kind of man who is likely to end up
being a bully
why because bullies typically pick the
target that's smaller than them the
weaker target but the weakest target
they can fight that's what a bully is a
bully isn't someone who goes in and
picks a fight and loses a bully is
someone who tortures small animals right
associate but that's what a bully is and
a weak nice man is far more likely to
bully his wife than a strong aggressive
but righteous man
so women please I have to get going here
if you've been looking for nice if
you've been looking for something that
that works and it that it just feels
right and fits ok I'd encourage you to
do a 180 right now if it's not been
working for you stop looking for nice
start looking for a backbone start
looking for principal start looking for
a man who you know might be a little bit
difficult look for look for a man where
you know what it may not just click it
may not fit perfectly right away there
may be some puzzle pieces that you're
going to have to fit that you're gonna
have to work with and then if he's the
right one link arms with him and love
together be tender together support
serve each other and be righteously
angry together about the same things
that's what you look for in a man not
nice see you next week
1 billion views
[Music]